i don't want to spare anyone's blushes
or i don't think this is a spoiler but
there is a lot of ball biting that goes
on yes in the film yeah they're attack
dogs ball biting ball balls right okay
wow going for a sensitive [ __ ] oh right
so you are half english i am i don't
know
actually my mother is from essex are we
surrounded
whereabouts i don't know
we're everywhere we're everywhere well
no my mother ran away from home when she
was really young oh right yeah ran away
from essex i don't blame her
you think you're a lot cooler and better
than you are and you go back i am yeah
thank you i am a lot cooler than i was
you were you were
saying that
it was yeah
you are fighting a lot of people in this
yeah yeah some of the people are just
like
men mountains i mean they're just like
seven foot two you must gotta think
really no man i'm joking
so you hold it keanu weaves was a fan of
the two ones man you're just like a
little person and you're looking for
things to do and sometimes the tv's on
and then the two ronnie's late at night
and they're running around making jokes
you don't understand and then you're
seeing boobs
you were on an airplane that had to make
an emergency landing yeah which we know
is true yes that's true um
exactly what you said ryan what was the
inside
have you ever seen a ghost
yeah no really no i've seen one and i've
felt them you know i mean you get vibes
from places you know i mean well let me
tell you about yeah i remember being a
kid in uh where was it new jersey my
sister was in that bed i was in this but
i was probably about nine we had a nanny
over there and i remember just sitting
there and i was looking up and towards
the doorway and then almost on this kind
of suit
with no body no legs nobody in it kind
of came in and went like this and then
disappeared
it was double-breasted it was white
you write an american bike or you write
a japanese british british bike yeah
right but awesome no norton commander
not in commando but also i've also had
some american iron but did you still
ride yeah well a little bit i know since
my last accident kind of like knocked a
window in my sails a little bit what
happened to you yeah i was on one of
them v rods and i tried to go around a
corner
were you at a high rate of speed what's
the point of being on a bike
the feeling of of being there of walking
the streets of the future
is really going to be breathtaking
you're breathtaking
you're all breathtaking
swayze was like okay you know you're
gonna have to catch me
and you're gonna have to do that and i
was like okay how many takes uh that one
we only did three
because i i got him
[Laughter]
good day a good day would be to sleep in
take a motorcycle ride
bike this guys
swim
have a nice lunch
um
then do some things that you probably
can't talk about on television
i want to ride a horse why don't i ride
a horse i'm trying to escape and so he
said that's a good idea
and so began the training because with
john wick he can't just ride a horse you
have to come off the saddle you're
supposed to fall under it hold on to the
pommel excuse me it's fine and then
shoot some guys
the next thing now you have a movie
coming out
and what is that called a movie coming
out uh little buddha is playing yes uh
even cowgirls get the blues by gus van
sant is playing
and uh just completed the film called
johnny mnemonic a science fiction film
with uh william gibson wrote it and
robert longo directed and what kind of a
character are you i'm the hero of course
what is your secret for always staying
down to earth
well i mean
gravity
are things beginning to get a little bit
icky in the mornings yeah it's that walk
the first walk where it's kind of like
oil
um
you know
then you get you kind of get your john
wayne on you know you're just kind of
like okay yeah
i'm just gonna go to the bathroom
tell the people how old you are i'm five
two
really yeah
i always think of you in your 30s i know
because he looks it yeah 52
look what happened in a year
what did i do for the last 12 months
i looked like that a year ago i really
did what do you think happens when we
die keanu reeves
i know that the ones who love us will
miss us
question though do they let you do that
i mean like when you're when you're
doing the scenes does the director say
more vocalization
um i mean often there's often so
there's nothing like it's like
they're like no that's not that's not
good no one comes like that
did you obviously didn't know i had a
crush on her all right oh wow
i can't believe you both had crushes on
each other and you you were so scared we
were working well i know but there's
haven't you ever had a romance with
somebody that you did a movie with
um
sounds like yes
i mean make that face whether it's
whether it's before or after i mean you
can wait until it's sure yeah but that's
so that so that chemistry was real
because you all really did both have
feelings like that yeah
it was nice yeah yeah yeah and
i mean she's so what's such a wonderful
person sandy come on out
look at this she tricks him and he's
like oh no
is she actually i don't want to look
no
not here
[Music]
sign from the film which is chilling to
everyone is well there's a couple yes
yes um what i'm thinking of is
something if the earth dies you die if
you die the earth survives right but the
other one is
um
i don't know your planet this is not
your planet this is not your planet
that's right it is not your planet well
it's kind of a nice concept it's a nice
kind of way to think about it well it's
it's true i'm going to stream this no we
don't own the planet we're lucky to be
here yes we are every day yeah
wow
you sure you don't want some fruit okay
i mean you don't have to yeah i could i
got no no it was rude of me to turn that
down actually so yeah
oh well granted i'll take a pump a
pomegranate well look wait before you
look at there's a lot of other things
there to get out look at that you
probably like that you rate a british
break
there's yeah pomegranate they get uh one
of them there's one of them
oh look at this is a little bit like
your name kiwano
what's a kiwano it's a very enigmatic
fruit man
people don't really know much about it
i mean it's very popular and the girls
enjoy it but nobody knows
uh you're going to see one of the first
professional jobs i i i got it's a
coca-cola commercial
roll tape
[Music]
is
yeah
very nice
talk to you ladies and gentlemen
now that was shot in canada is that
correct yes in the winter oh my god you
couldn't tell though no so how do they
do that how do they make it look like
you're out there actually sweating in
the hot the summer sun well you know the
fake sweat actually it was a good
experience for me because it was like a
three-day shoot it was one of my first
jobs you had to pretend it was hot in
the winter you know that scene with the
end there we improvised um
you know is well actually that's another
part of it but anyway um and then you
know there was that classic thing of you
know
a coke you had that right that moment
where the director's like you're on a
desert island
you getting a coke say a coke and drink
it and that wasn't good enough and so it
was like it turned into like okay you're
uh
oh then i went to women pretend it's the
most beautiful woman
anyway uh
did you in the course of the filming did
you have to drink a lot of coke consumer
well yeah
yeah the director yeah yeah that wasn't
right drink it again
um so i ended up in the bus
like just kind of like i couldn't i was
like in contortions and i was like
what's happening to me
you know it's like and i guess i had i
was having a sugar shock
caffeine
it was a good start yes it was